I am ready Chris
[Music]
are you ready shader
go find Robert Downey jr. x' career at
the bottom of the cocaine when it got
here no that's a Ouija board from only
you and disturbing romantic company no
that's the baby from LMFAO you found it
you found his career at the bhava Gupta
you found Iron Man oh my god we had so
many other jokes in here and you just
succeeded you know and I'm guessing
they're jokes anyway we had a Wesley
Snipes tax return here cuz he did you at
Marshall's we head oh y'all going off
from back to school we had the
soundtrack to danger zone I really hate
the fact you did this so welcome we have
gingerbread man we have the shaggy dog
with Tim Allen
we had the syringe from Gothic ugly he's
that love and Halle Berry by God that
was way too fast but on the other hand
Oh things feel so good this is pop quiz
hotshot I'm the Nostalgia Critic and
ever since I was a child I always wanted
to play games quoting movies and TV with
my friends the only problem was I had no
friends well now that I have power I can
take my friends by force with the help
of my new pal general anesthetic I can
kidnap all the friends I want and force
them to answer questions it might save
by the Bell style scent there will be
laughs trivia those disturbing cartoons
that give you night terrors but most of
all there will be fun
the laughter and joy will last however
long I want
heads up America or this is pop quiz
hotshot
[Music]
well at this point I would usually say
take the bags off but we couldn't get
the bag on ant-man's head over there
welcome to pop quiz hotshot we're funny
gets you money the contestants are
kidnapped and the loser dies now don't
worry that's only a figure of speech we
see you more as victims than losers
shader what's the story with you you
should know you kidnapped me
I'll admit I came out to you because I
looked at you I said you looked the
least threatening and I thought this is
the guy less likely to fight back you
have a very terrible opinion of film
students you know I don't think I do
because that is the first thing I said
why I looked at you that looks like a
film student but I really must ask what
is with the Japanese Lord helmet get up
there I thought you would know you're
the one that kidnapped me you and your
evil organization I didn't put you in
the suit
somebody did Chris it says here that you
do a really really good Chris Rock
impression I don't but I do a
halfway-decent impression from time to
time gotta kiss me on the right day well
we definitely caught you on the right
day and we're not gonna let you go
either cuz that is so Mary isn't darling
Oh Chris Rock you make me both ashamed
and happy to be white but we're gonna
play a game here right now and we have
to know what those rules are at dinner
my aesthetic won't you tell us those
rules each contestant is asked a series
of questions involving the sounds of
quotes
if the contestant does not know the
answer but can make the Nostalgia Critic
laugh 10 Flint's are still given but
look out for the spaz he's the first one
to hit their buzzer when they appear
ends the round while the other has to
pay the penalty through round 2 where
the quotes get even harder the winner
with the most points face off against
from the sounds of critic and a
one-on-one match if the contestant wins
they walk out with a cash prize and also
their lives if they lose the cash prize
will be added to the next contestants
winning
so let's just jump right in there metal
pac-man in which Russell Crowe film did
he say at my signal unleash hell Gods
and Generals in that movie you know for
a superhero films doing you're not
knowing your films very well like I'm
gonna watch a Russell Crowe film okay
give them ten points for that because
you've got mad props and be Sir Chris
what film had the whisper lines if you
build it he will come
Field of Dreams yes shader which Batman
actors set the line it's not who I am
underneath but what I do that defines me
Val Kilmer you are fucking killing me
right now okay you were dressed as a
superhero you know it's not Val Kilmer
Chris which anime film feature the line
squirrel up yes shader in Shrek 2 when
the guards discovered catnip on puss and
boots
what is his reply definitely yes I will
give you that point just for the exits
it was so authentic Chris what a tease
kid's film had the line Wolf Man has an
arms put your hand down shader wolf man
to the wolf gardening you know I'm gonna
give you those points because if they
ever did make a monster squad 2 that
would be the title under it shader and
the matrix what actors said human beings
are a disease a cancer on this planet
you are a plague and we are the cure
Agent Smith yes Chris finish this line
from taken if you don't I will look for
you I will find you and I will kill you
yes you'll be very bad a lot later
shaker in what movie did Robin Williams
say poetry Beauty romance love these are
what we stay alive for there's bullets
aside I was going to say if you didn't
quote the movie that had poetry in the
tile then yes Chris in the Nolan Batman
films which characters said in their
last moments people show you who they
really are the Joker
yes shader what sci-fi classic had the
eye
Ronna Klein you know the saying human
see human dude
monkeys in a basket is that even a film
what are you
it was my student film what a v8 the
disturbing thing about that is you were
kind of close Chris in the original Star
Wars trilogy what character said he's
more machine than man now twisted and
evil Darth Skeletor I mean no you're
trying to make that funny if I'm giving
you the points anyway I think you're
staying next to darts yama torque don't
Skeletor in which movie did adam
sandler's say please get out of my van
Halen t-shirt before you jinx the band
and they break up
was it warning in suck in can't make
that promise one he didn't suck it
yeah I gotta give it to him I like
wedding singer Chris what movie
character said I'm bad and that's good I
will never be good and that's not bad
there's no one I'd rather be than me
wreck-it Ralph yes shader
according to gunnery sergeant Hartman in
Full Metal Jacket only two things come
from Texas what are they and more
importantly can we say it am i MA Duke
and my balls you are quite the enigma
shader you are a fascinating specimen
that I'm giving 10 points to Chris
what's Will Ferrell movie head the line
I'm in a glass cage of emotion a night
at the Roxbury to the Roxbury Inge you
know you had a good run but it's not
gonna save you this time it's one of
only two will throw movies that anyone
knows anchorman shader in Encino man
what actor said in Spanish the cheese is
old and moldy where's the bathroom
the caveman you're actually surprisingly
close again it was Brendan Fraser and I
almost had to give you points because
you avoided a poly short movie but
everybody's done that has nothing that
special Chris what classic monster movie
had the lines oh no it wasn't the
airplanes it was beauty that killed the
Beast
King Kong yes shaker in the Disney film
Beauty and the Beast Bell calls Gaston
positively primeval what is his response
you look like a man who knows his Disney
Princesses when I was a lad I bore dozen
eggs every morning to get large I
would've given you the points with you
Sonya but no it was why thank you though
Cris finish this Bruce Campbell line
from army of Darkness good bad I'm blank
black I'm giving you ten points for that
because I think he is too oh Jesus
Christ I hate those fucking things okay
it looks like shader has avoided the
spaz attack so that means Chris you must
face the penalty it'll be a penalty of
my choosing and you know what I want you
to answer all the following questions
like Chris Rock
like I said proud and ashamed to be
white whenever I hear you well we get
you change into your Chris Rock get up
shader well watch the cartoon so tell me
more about your mother
well I killed her when I was just a
little boy and do you ever think you
could do something like that again
alright Chris you look exactly like
Chris identical the only thing this is
the little gap but we knew if we put
black paint in there it probably talks
and we wait to live for a little bit
longer we're just gonna go right into
round 2 or the questions get a little
harder so here we go
Chris what movie had a motor-car
described as our fine for vendored
friend a motor car named desire
that can't last you forever but yes I am
giving you ten points for that shader
which movie featured the way harsh
insult you're a virgin who can't drive
your autobiography you know what I'm
gonna give you the point because you got
a Saved by the Bell
audience reacts of a man I got to give
me credit for that the movie was
clueless by the way clearly a film I
thought you'd be a fan of Chris in
Unforgiven which actors said we all have
a coming get Clint Eastwood yes shader
which actors said greed for lack of a
better word is good greed is right greed
works in the movie Wall Street penny
wise from monopoly good guess it was in
fact one of like only two people anyone
remembers from Wall Street Michael
Douglas fritz finished this quote Robin
Williams final line and Good Will
Hunting is son of a bitch you ain't
never had a friend like me
god damn you Chris Rock give him the 10
points
damn it it was actually he stole my line
which you actually did shader in
serenity what character said going on a
year now
and ain't nothing Twix mine others that
ain't been run on batteries you have no
idea how tricky that was to say no
Reynold no it was actually Kaylee again
really shocked you're not a fan of that
show you look like you walked right off
of it
Chris which Tarantino movie is this line
from kill white people and get paid for
it what's not to like I am so glad I'm
asking you this one is Chris Rock Django
Unchained goddamn right I just love
hearing Chris Rock say Django Unchained
shader from what Spielberg movie is this
line from Stern if this factory ever
produces a shell that can actually be
fired I'll be very unhappy Schindler's
List really a guy dresses like that you
don't know all these movies but you know
Schindler's List what kind of childhood
did you have none of your business
Don't Ask Don't Tell Chris in the
Sandlot what famous character said
heroes get remembered
but legends never die follow your heart
kids Elmo's name but this is the brother
at the end of the movie mad props to
that guy he was right
that was beautiful you're wrong Babe
Ruth shader in The Wizard of Oz which
characters said some people without
brains do an awful lot of talking don't
they
Dorothy no scarecrow you were right on
the second one I'm so close to giving
you that but you know what you said
Dorothy first Chris really Dorothy the
brains was in there is Chris in Silence
of the Lambs I mean she just says it
brains he has no brains much like you
right now wearing that are you having
that okay you know what look he's got a
gun I'm just saying he's got a gun what
better don't do what walk back yeah yeah
tough guy yeah go watch your Schindler's
List not Wizard of Oz you know Chris his
sounds of the Lambs Hannibal Lecter ate
his census takers
what with what and what with a side of
fava beans and a nice Chianti
close the what did he is brains liver oh
that hurts
dad listen we do guys in brain questions
lately it's not your strong point today
shader in the Simpsons episode where
Homer became an astronaut which
characters said and I for one would like
to salute our new ant overlords Kent
Brockman yes Chris
which actor asked in No Country for Old
Men what business is it of yours where
I'm from friend Oh Javier Bardem I just
love hearing Chris Rock pronounce that
name right yes give it to him
shader in a league of their own again
I'm film I'm sure you saw to what
actress did Rosie O'Donnell again I'm
sure one of your favorites say seriously
you think there's anyone left in this
country who hasn't seen your bosoms
herself in the mirror Wow harsh harsh
hate for Rosie O'Donnell that definitely
deserves ten points right there it was
actually Madonna which picture Chris in
Goldfinger when bond hears that the
woman in front of him is named Pussy
Galore what is his response hell yeah
plus it was actually I must be drinking
I'm holding back a lot laughter right
now from you but I'm pressing on me I'm
pressing on sheiter what movie had the
line he got a real pretty mouth auntie
delivers yes even if you never saw the
movie you could just guess that that was
the right one
well that's mostly cuz of Rocco's murder
right for that one you look like a guy
who would watch Rocko's Modern Life
Chris name the racing movie based on
this quote ask any racer any real racer
it doesn't matter if you win by an inch
or a mile winnings winning turbo no Fast
and the Furious shader finish this line
from All About Eve I know you're gonna
get this one fasten your seat belt
it's going to be a bumpy ride a bumpy
night
very close I'm surprised they usually
show that way Schindler's List and that
is the buzzer ending the round and it
looks like oh it's close we have Chris
with a hundred and forty and shader with
a hundred and ten so very very close but
I'm sure a guy like that you'll turn up
somewhere in some ditch gentle aesthetic
go ahead lead him away that time into
the wrong direction a pop quiz hotshot
and live in the Chicagoland area send a
video via YouTube stating your name a
and why you think it would be a good
contestant
[Music]
welcome back to pop quiz hotshot Chris
congratulations you're now going to
battle against the critic in our final
round I'm going to be giving seven
questions to one who answers to most
wins the game the one who doesn't swim
Chris have you defeat the critic you get
to win this this priceless jewelry
viewing spot at a store just down the
street also a hundred and fifty dollars
in cash and of course you're live
fantastic all right
this round is going to be about Disney
villain songs I'm going to be naming the
lyric and then you have to give me the
movie that it's based on
Chris are you ready yes are you ready
chief do it let's begin
Chris so prepare for the coup of the
century Lion King correct critic go
ahead make your choice Little Mermaid
correct Chris choose me or your pyre be
mine or you will burn The Hunchback of
Notre Dame correct critic his assets
frozen his venues chosen it's the ends
of the earth will be aladdin correct
Chris are you ready are you ready
transformation sensual princess in the
product correct critic we are Siamese if
you please
lady in the Tramp correct Chris trusted
me Justin me shut your eyes plan before
time and correct
critic from the brain that brought you
the Big Bend caper the Great Mouse
Detective correct Chris I'm the
magnificent marvelous mad madam min all
Thor's gonna incorrect critic it's gold
and it's mine mine my focus correct
Chris with a hip hip and a clippity-clop
he's gone looking for a top to chop
uh-uh
goodbye mr. crane I'm going to accept
that critic Jul 8 2013 8
well well well what have we here Sandy
Claws uh-oh I'm really scared
Nightmare Before Christmas correct and
the winner is I have to say Chris you
have been such a good opponent and
because you did such a good Chris Rock
impression I'm gonna kill you fast so go
ahead and get him going good I love Tim
in rush hour I will see you next time on
pop quiz hotshot Big Lebowski additions
hey - so we tried to kill you and it
didn't work
why is that well your secret the truth
is I'm actually oh oh my god nice to
meet you Gary Anderson writer-artist
dark champion shader
is that a comic of some sort why yes it
is in fact it is a webcomic that I have
on the.com
I forget the website but you can find it
with just the google searches also on
deviantART and tumblr so the whole
reason you came on this show was just to
plug yourself yep
well I Got News for you we're gonna plug
you right now get get home
super Arbor gave her moons and on your
face
[Music]